let's make the CLE a unit of measurement
one CLE would be one level of
abstraction away from the reality of a
situation for example you ask me for a
hamburger at one CQ if you asked me for
a hamburger and I gave you a raccoon at
two cqes if you ask me for a hamburger
but it turns out I don't really exist
where I was originally standing a
picture of a hamburger rests on the
ground at three cqes you awake as a
hamburger you start screaming only to
have Special Sauce fly from your lips
the world is in
seia at for cules why are we speaking
German a mime cries Softly As He cradles
a young cow your grandfather stares at
you as the cow falls apart into patties
you look down only to see me with
Pickles for eyes I am singing the song
that gives birth to the
universe at five CES you ask for a
hamburger I give you a Hamburg Burger
you raise it to your lips and take a
bite your eye twitches
involuntarily across the street a father
of three falls down the stairs you
swallow and look down at the hamburger
in your hands I give you a hamburger you
in your hands you cannot swallow there
are children at the top of the stairs a
pickle shifts uneasily under the
bun I give you a
hamburger you look at my face and I am
pleading with you the children are
crying now you raise the hamburger to
your lips tears stream down your face as
you take a bite I give you a
hamburger you are on your knees you
plead with me to go across the street I
hear only children's
laughter I give you a
hamburger you are screaming as you fall
down the stairs I am your child you
cannot see anything you take a bite of
the hamburger the concrete rushes up to
meet you you awake with a start in your
own bed your eye twitches
involuntarily I give you a
hamburger as you kill me I do not make a
sound I give you a
hamburger at six cqes you ask me for a
hamburger my attempt to reciprocate is
cut brutally short as my body
experiences a sudden lack of electrons
across a variety of hidden Dimensions
you are dismayed John Lennon hands me an
Apple but it slips through my fingers I
am reborn as an ocelot you disapprove a
crack Echoes through the universe in
defiance of conventional physics as
cosmological background noise shifts
from Randomness to a perfect a flat
children everywhere stop what they are
doing and hum along in Perfect Pitch
with the background radiation birds fall
from the sky as the sun engulfs the
Earth you hesitate momentarily before
allowing yourself to assume the locus of
all knowledge ENT trippy crumbles as you
peruse the information contained within
the universe a small librarian Phoenix
ceases to exist you stumble under the
weight of everythingness your mouth
opens up to cry out and collapses around
your body before blinking you out of the
spatial plane you exist only within the
fourth dimension The Fountain Head of
all knowledge rolls along the ground and
collides with a small dog my head tastes
sideways as SpaceTime is reestablished
you blink back into the corporeal world
disoriented only for me to hand you a
hamburger as my body collapses under the
strain of reconstitution the universe
has reasserted itself a particular small
dog is fed steak for the rest of its
natural life you die in a freak accident
moments later and your soul works at the
returns desk for the Phoenix Library you
disapprove your disapproval sends
ripples through the interdimensional
void between life and death the small
child begins to cry as he walks toward
the stairway where his father stands
[Music]